So in 1832,
as we saw at the end last time,
volar went to uh,
work for,
uh,
most of a month with [inaudible] and together they worked on the oil of bitter
almonds,
which is making its way around it's Benzaldehyde,
which is making its way around here.
Uh,
so there's the bottle that's coming around.
What did you notice about it?
Where is it?
What do you notice about it?
Devin?
Yeah,
what does it smell like in almonds there?
Turn it around and look at the,
turn it upside down.
What do you notice?
Yeah,
it's half solid.
Benzaldehyde is the oil of bitter almonds,
not the solid of bitter almonds.
What does it say on the label?
Written by hand.
Okay.
Somebody initials.
J W.
So it was opened in 1995,
13 years ago when it was opened,
it was liquid.
Now it's half solid.
How do you figure that?
Yeah.
Well,
something must've happened.
So what did it react with and the bottle,
you and Joe Oxygen.
Okay.
So oil,
a bitter almonds.
They analyzed seven h six o o
and they found that it reacted with oxygen to get c seven h six o two right.
They also reacted it with bromine.
The halogens were common as we'll see for reagents in those days.
He got cs seven h five OBR.
They reacted it with chlorine and also that product with potassium iodide or
ammonia or lead sulfide,
and they got all these compounds and what did they do with them when they got
him?
They smelled them.
Right?
What?
What was the main thing they did?
And that's not the way it's true that they probably taste that they tasted it,
but that's not the main thing they did.
That gave them
unique information.
What about the weight?
What was the main technique that we've been talking about?
All the time data.
They did elemental analysis,
ultimate analysis of what the ratio of the elements.
So that's what they had,
right?
So big deal.
What do you get from the analysis?
What can you infer here where these guys,
you can now compete with them,
right?
This is what they found out during that month of experimentation and they came
up with a theory that co revolutionized organic chemistry as,
as of that time and for the next 20 years.
So what did they notice,
Clara?
Pardon me?
Well,
how would you know it's a chain?
The numbers don't tell you it's a chain.
What?
Well,
it is.
It's got hydrogen and carbon in it.
That's true.
But they also have oxygen and nitrogen Flory and other things.
What could you make out of this,
Ryan?
Yeah.
All of them have at least c seven h five some of them have more hydrogen than
that,
but nothing has less than c seven or less than h five can anybody carry that any
further?
Pardon me?
Yeah,
he's 70 years of violence.
Yeah.
What would they have called it?
The thing that that you have at there and then it reacts and gives this that or
the other thing.
What did Lavoie Z,
I call it the base or the radical,
but can you,
but actually the real radical is more than h five the thing that persists.
What else?
Oh,
so c seven h five o persists through all these transformations.
So it looks like that some sort of a core that gets modified,
die.
But if it's there all the time,
it's like a radical,
right?
So it was called the benzos wheel radical.
They thought up that name at that time.
And the idea of using the suffix,
why l to denote a radical.
So if you did note the Benzo radical by Bz,
you see that you started the oil of bitter almonds is B,
z h and then the acid is BZ,
o h and the acid chloride is BZ cl and br and I on Nh two and two B's,
C's together with ass
at the end.
Okay?
So a radical can be the base of more than just an acid,
right?
Lovaas had the idea that you reacted with oxygen and you get an acid.
But here you can react it with all sorts of different things and get different
compounds.
But the base is still there.
The right,
the Benzo radical.
So this gave rise to the idea of organic dualism.
Remember we had this dualism last time.
There were positive things and negative things and they could associate and
trade partners.
But maybe the difference in organic chemistry is that you have radicals,
things that are Poe plus plus or minus,
but there are more complicated than just single Adams.
There are combinations of elements that function in organic chemistry.
That's what makes us different from inorganic according to this theory.
So then the idea is to find all these organic radicals that make organic radic
organic chemistry special.
So during the 1830s,
the,
these compound radicals were discovered everywhere.
For example,
in Germany,
[inaudible] found asset deal and Bunsen in Heidelberg found caca deal,
which is named because it smells so awful,
right?
Or buts alias in Sweden,
found Ethel or fire IA in Italy,
got salads,
seal and do mock,
got a whole bunch of them in Paris,
methyl sent Amiel,
Ceto,
ethylene.
All of these radicals were discovered.
So the thought those,
this is the way to organize organic chemistry and that theory,
the dualism,
uh,
applied to organic theory.
The radical theory survives today in our nomenclature,
right?
So for example,
we talk about ethyl chloride,
that's not one word.
It's two words with the space,
right?
And the reason is it's dualistic.
It's a positive Ethel and a minus chlorine,
right?
So it's two things that have come together.
Okay.
Now the eel part that a volar and,
and uh,
and Leiby thought up comes from a Greek word [inaudible],
which means wood or matter.
So it's the substance of stuff.
Okay.
So it's the,
so now ether was something that had been known for a long time and it came from
a Greek root,
which means to shine.
So in the 17 hundreds,
it was sort had been applied to the sky that it was transferred from the idea of
shining to the idea that clear sky,
and from that to a colorless liquid.
So when they distilled something out of,
uh,
out of alcohol that had been treated with acid and they've got this clear stuff
that was clear as the sky,
they called it ether,
right?
Which we call die ethyl ether nowadays.
So,
so that's where ether came from.
So hence f eel was the matter that appears in ether.
So it was like two Benza wheel radicals with sulfur.
Right?
You can have two ethyl radicals with oxygen,
right?
And that was then f Eel,
The material of ether.
Okay.
How about methyl?
Well,
methy comes from the Greek word,
meaning wine or spirit.
Right?
And the eel that same route,
but a different meeting this time.
Remember,
it can mean matter that was the one before,
or it can mean wood.
And in this case it means would.
So what does it mean?
Math?
Ill if the ill means not the substance of but means would pardon me.
From wood,
from wood.
The spirit from wood.
So you've heard methanol called wood alcohol,
right?
Cause you'd get it from distilling it.
So the EAD,
but,
but the first word was meth.
Ian and Ian is the Greek feminine.
Patronymics it means the daughter of an e.
All of those are like that,
like per Stephanie or uh,
or Antigony.
Uh,
it means the one who goes against her parents and so on.
So Ian was a great,
so,
so what did meth,
Ilene mean?
It meant the daughter of would spirits.
So the theory was that would spirits was that is wood.
Alcohol was a combination of methylene plus water.
So methylene us if out if what alcohol is ch three o h then methyl Ian was ch
two which you,
which then add water and you get what?
Alcohol.
So that's where the name Meth Ian came from.
Right?
So then in 1840,
that was 1835.
So five years later they decided that they needed the radical ch three.
So they named it meth deal from methylene.
Right.
And then,
uh,
ethylene came,
that name came in 1852 because it was related to Ethel,
which had already been named the same way that methylene was related to methyl.
Okay.
So that's where these names came from.
It,
they all have their root in the radical theory.
Now that's c one and c two methyl and ethyl.
How about c?
Three and c Ford.
You know what they're named
route.
See,
how about c three?
Do you know what c three alcohol is?
Pro Bowl and see for butyl.
So where do those names come from?
Okay.
C three h seven is [inaudible].
And by the same reasoning as before,
c three h six is propylene or protein.
Sometimes it's shortened,
okay.
And Beutel and butylene or butane.
Okay.
Now butylene comes the c four acid is [inaudible] acid,
which had already been named because it's the stuff that makes rancid butter
smell bad,
okay?
So people worked it up and found butyric acid.
So that's where butyl comes from.
But how about pro ball?
It has a very much more interesting origin.
Okay?
Protos Means First and pee on means fat.
So [inaudible] was the first fat in what sense?
Well,
these carboxylic acids came from fats,
right?
And they were called fatty acids and they'd behave like fats.
They dissolve in organic solvents,
right?
But the very,
the ones with the fewest number of carbons with just one carbon,
that's formic acid that you get by destructive distillation of ants or acidic
acid for vinegar.
Those are miscible with water.
But the c three is the first one that's not freely miscible with water and
behaves more like a fat,
right?
So that's the first fatty acid is pro pro propionic acid.
Uh,
so pro bill properly and are the see threes.
Okay.
After that you get into numbers,
right?
The roots for numbers.
So jump Baptiste.
Dante do ma was the successor of,
of uh,
daily sac as the,
as the spokesman for four French chemistry.
You see,
he was born on the 14th of July,
a reasonable date for somebody to lead French chemistry in 1800.
So for 84 years,
well for part of 84 years,
he was the leader of French chemistry.
There he is with some uh,
decoration on,
I'm not sure what it is.
I'd like to find out.
So he was the post and the poliano guardian of the French tradition of
chemistry.
The French had a,
what most people regard as a terrible system,
which is they had chairs,
you know,
for professors,
but you can have more than one chair.
So a single individual could tie up three different appointments and you didn't
have as many people able to exercise their ingenuity in developing chemistry.
So he had the chair of both all at the Sorbonne,
also the Ecole Polytechnique in the a call they made scene
and he was a persistent opponent of liebig and Burt's alias.
Uh,
but in 1837 after this radical stuff got going and he had discovered for
radicals himself of which he was quite pleased.
Uh,
he and Lee big happened to meet during a speaking tour in England and they got
in conversation and do mod decided on the basis of that meeting though not
leaving,
that they were now great friends and could collaborate from here on in.
So he wrote this long thing and flowery French in 1837 a note on the present
state of organic chemistries.
This is seven or five years after the radical theory began.
He said,
60 years of hardly passed since the ever a memorable time when this same
assembly he was speaking to the,
to the Paris Academy,
heard the first discussions of the fertile chemical doctrine,
which we owe to the genius of Love was eight.
This short span of time has sufficed to examine fully the most delicate
questions of inorganic chemistry.
And anyone can easily convince himself that this branch of our knowledge
possesses almost everything that it can with the methods of observation
available.
So check off in organic chemistry.
We got that now.
Okay.
They're barely remain a few cracks here and there to fill in.
So this is the,
the persistent myopia of leaders of science.
As I mentioned before,
when we were speaking of Lavoie,
Zia the certainly persist at Dell today.
Uh,
so we do,
Ma goes on in a word how with the help of the laws of inorganic chemistry.
Incidentally,
this is all one sentence.
Of course,
this is in a word,
right?
So he,
he really liked speaking,
right?
Flowery language.
How with the help of the laws of inorganic chemistry couldn't want to explain
and classifies such varied substances as one obtains from organic bodies and
which nearly always are formed only of carbon,
hydrogen and oxygen to which elements nitrogen is sometimes joined.
So if,
if it's all in the analysis of what Adam's are there,
how can you have so many different things?
All right.
This was the great and beautiful question of natural philosophy.
A question well designed to excite the highest degree of competition among
canvas name too,
right?
For once resolved,
the most beautiful triumphs were promised to science,
the mysteries of plants,
the mysteries of animal life would be unveiled before our eyes.
We would see as the key to all of the changes of matter so sudden,
so swift,
so singular that occur in animals and plants.
More importantly,
we would find means of duplicating them in our laboratories.
This would make a good research proposal,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
we're not afraid to say it and it is not an assertion which we make lightly.
This great and beautiful question is today answered.
It only remains the follow through on all the consequences which the solution
and tails in fact,
to produce with three or four elements,
such varied combinations more very perhaps than those which make up the whole.
In organic kingdom,
nature has chosen a path as simple as it was unexpected for with elements.
She has made compounds which behave in all their properties like elements
themselves.
That is radicals,
right?
That persists through these reactions and this we are convinced is the entire
secret of organic chemistry.
That's great and beautiful question is answered.
It only remains to follow through the consequences compounds which behave like
elements.
Thus organic chemistry possesses in its own elements which sometimes play the
role of chlorine or oxygen.
What does he mean play the role of chlorine and oxygen?
How come radical sometimes play the role of chlorine and oxygen?
What would that role be?
Pardon me?
No.
What roles do things play in this theory that he's using?
Okay.
Lucas plus and minus,
plus and minus.
So sometimes they're like Gloria in her oxygen.
What does that mean?
Sometimes they're negative,
right?
And sometimes on the contrary,
they play the role of metals.
Sometimes they're positive Cyanna,
Jenna,
mid Benzo wheel,
the radicals of ammonia,
of aliphatic,
of alcohol and analogous substances.
These are the true elements with which organic chemistry operates.
To discover these radicals.
To study them,
to characterize them has been our daily study for 10 years.
Okay,
so seven plus in their binders sometimes.
Nonetheless,
our opinions of appeared to defer and then with each of us drawn on by the heat
of our battle with nature,
there are rows between us discussions who's liveliness we both regret.
Actually,
when we were able to discuss questions which separated this in several friendly
meetings,
we soon realized that we were in agreement on the principles.
We then understood that United we could undertake a task before which either of
us in isolation would have recoiled.
We will analyze every organic substance to establish reliably what sort of
radical it refers to.
So that is what everybody should do.
Then you'll know all about organic chemistry.
Each of us has in fact opened his laboratory to all young men who were motivated
by true love of science.
They have seen all understood all we,
we have worked under their eyes and I've had them work under hours in such a way
that we are surrounded by young rivals who are the hope of science and whose
work will be added to ours and mingle with rs four we'll have been conceived in
the same spirit and carried out by the same method,
right?
So if everybody does what we say they should do,
then we got it.
Okay.
This is not an effort.
Can See for personal gain or in the interest of narrow vanity far be it from us.
No.
And in the collaboration,
which is perhaps unheard of in the history of science,
this is an undertaking in which we hope to interest every chemist in Europe.
So everyone should work on this.
So we'll,
we'll go to the funding agencies and tell them this is the only kind of research
you should fund.
Forget these other guys out there.
That's his true love of science and conceived in the same spirit and carried out
by the same method.
So this is Megalomania and doesn't show much imagination,
uh,
now,
but there was a problem with dualism.
So for example,
suppose you have benzoyl chloride,
which remember was read by reacting Benzaldehyde or benzoyl hydride with
chlorine and you get the benzoyl chloride and hcl is the other product.
Now hcl is quite clear.
It's h plus and C l minus.
What's Ben's a wheel chloride.
It's obviously Ben's a wheel plus and c l minus.
And what problem does that create?
What Russel?
Aha,
but how do you get benzoyl hydride plus plus,
right?
So there's something weird going on.
So this is a problem.
Uh,
in 1840 [inaudible] and 1850s,
the French discovered a competing theory,
uh,
or invented,
I should say,
a competing theory called the substitution theory or the type theory or the
unitary theory as opposed to the dualistic theory,
the plus minus idea.
So these began to compete with one another and it started at a ball in the
[inaudible] palace in 1830.
This picture is from 40 years later,
37 years later.
But what happened is the,
they got the ball started,
all the people came dressed up fancy,
and they began to cough and choke because the room was filled with some noxious
gas.
And when they discovered it came from the candles,
they asked do model to look into it.
And he identified the culprit is hcl because it turned out that the w the
candles were very white.
The wax had been bleached with chlorine,
and when they were burned,
hcl was given off.
So the question is,
what is it that holds chlorine?
How did this fat in the candles fix chlorine gas?
Well,
you're in a position to understand that.
Now we can think about mechanisms,
in fact,
two ways that that the,
the hydrocarbon could fix glory.
Now suppose we try and there's chlorine that is being used to bleach the stuff.
Let's try for a homo Lumo approach.
What makes chlorine reactive?
Yeah.
Hi Homo or low Lumo.
What's unusual about chlorine?
Pardon me?
Why do you say so Claire?
What is the,
what is the low Lou vote,
right?
The sigma star,
CLC l,
which is low because chlorine has big nuclear charge.
Okay,
now we need a homo to react with it.
Now,
one of the more interesting hydrocarbons in this regard is one that had been
known already for,
uh,
40 years to react with chlorine.
And it was because of that reaction.
It was called the old Fiat gas and was by this time known to be [inaudible].
Right?
So we would write it with a double bond,
all of Fiat because Ola oil and find to make,
so it's the stuff that makes oil right and this,
and we'll see the reaction that makes oil here.
It's reaction with chlorine.
So what makes the old defiant gas reactive
haven't,
right.
So poor overlap makes a high homo and remember the name of it.
Pod.
So the Pi electrons because of poor overlap or high homo.
So we can use those electrons to mix with the low Lumo.
And you have one of these make and break situations and chloride leaves and you
get this thing which has a positive charge.
Now that thing itself is reactive.
What do you make?
Where is the low Lumo in this one?
Pardon me?
Can I speak up please?
Where the positive charges,
there's a vacant adore battle on carbon and atomic orbital.
A carbon that's not shared.
So there's a low luma.
Where's the high homeboy?
You've got that to Virginia.
Yeah.
Chlorine has unshared pairs,
right?
Bingo.
So in fact,
both those things happen at once.
It's not that one happens.
And then the other,
both those things happen at once.
And you can see it by looking at molecular orbitals.
So there's the homo of the,
of the ethylene or all Phi gas and the Sigma Star Lumo.
So those things mix the blue orbitals overlap and mixed shift electrons toward
the other one.
The chloride breaks away,
but at the same time,
the homo of the chlorine mixes with the Lumo of the ethylene.
So you're making two bonds at once,
two pairs of electrons.
So you make that three membered ring with two new bonds and the chloride is,
we said breaks away.
Okay.
So we've got that,
uh,
that's substance now
and now it itself is reactive.
Can you see what would be reactive about that cat eye and intermediate?
What are you're probably looking at for a Lumo or a homo?
A Lumo.
Angela,
you have an idea of what could be a Lumo here.
It's true that the chlorine has a positive charge.
Does it have a vacant orbital unoccupied molecular orbital?
No,
it turns out it's got to unshared pairs.
So it doesn't have any or it's not like the carbon plus was,
but the plus we'll make orbitals low in energy.
So what's a vacant orbital of this thing?
Oh,
it's God is sigma bonds.
Yeah.
Well,
what makes us suppose all you have in your molecule is sigma bonds,
but you want to an unusually low energy,
vacant orbital,
right?
The plus charge will help,
but what is,
what orbital will you have sigma star now you've got two choices.
You've got carbon,
carbon or carbon chlorine,
which one's more likely to be low energy?
Why
say chlorine as a high effective,
efficient,
high chlorine has the high nuclear charge.
So a sigma star,
carbon chlorine,
would it be big on carbon or big on chlorine?
Sam Big on carbon because the bonding or,
but it was big on chlorine,
right?
This is the kind of stuff we were talking about.
So Sigma Star and there it is.
Okay.
There is a localized sigma star,
big on chlorine,
the black,
uh,
big on carbon,
the black one,
small on chlorine and anti-bonding between them.
Now what are you going to,
there's the low luma.
What do you have for a high homo to react with it?
You have to think back to what's been happening.
Sure.
What
the chloride that you had at the beginning that you lost in the first step.
Okay,
so we bring it over here so it'll have good overlap.
It comes up and makes a new bond that may can break,
and you get that.
And that was the reaction in 1795 that resulted in ethylene being called the Ola
[inaudible] gas because this is the oil that was made by reacting it with
chlorine.
So that was already a very old reaction at this time,
the oil of Dutch chemists,
because it was for Dutch chemists who reported that oil.
Okay,
so there's one way that you can fix chlorine,
make it part of a,
of a mall,
hydrocarbon molecule.
It's addition to an alkane.
So if the hydrocarbons are unsaturated,
if they have some double bonds,
then you'll react with chlorine to fix the chlorine.
So that's one possibility.
But how about if you don't have a double bond?
How about if you have methane,
what's the problem now
in doing?
And that analogous reaction,
Sherwin,
pardon me?
You don't have a pie.
You don't have a low Lumo so you can't do a homo Lumo reaction,
right?
These are our,
our uh,
our model saturated alkanes like methane,
our model of things that aren't unusually higher,
unusually low.
So we have to have another trick.
And here's the trick that the chlorine chlorine bond is weak.
It's only 58 kilocalories per mole.
And one of the reasons for that is that the chlorine has so many unshared
payers.
So you mix,
if you were trying to form a Pi orbital in chlorine,
you have two electrons and the p orbital here,
two electrons on the p orbital here,
or they overlap.
Is that going to be bonding?
If you mix these two orbitals,
you'll obviously mix them when you mix two herbal,
as you get a lower one in a higher one,
will it be bonding?
This one will be bonding,
but this one is anti-bonding everybody with me on this now.
So Kate,
what would you say?
Is it going to be net favorable or unfavorable
to electrons went down and energy to electrons went up in energy,
but the ones that went up went up a little more than the down went down so well,
that's unfavorable.
So having so many unshared pairs weakens the single bond.
So chlorine has a weak bond.
Now still it's,
it's worth 35 k for 58 kilocalories per mole.
Pardon me?
Which is plenty strong.
It doesn't just break.
You've got to do something to help it to break.
And what you can do is I,
I've made it in this weird color,
which is hard to see.
Why
anybody know?
Pardon me?
Color of chlorine.
It absorbs visible light.
Now how does it take on energy?
One of the absorbs visible light.
Where does the energy go in the molecule?
It's anybody know
data can't hear very well.
Electrons go from orbitals to hire orbitals so you can put,
then the next higher orbital is sigma star.
And what happens if you take an electron and put it in Sigma Star,
right?
Breaks the bond,
That's what happened up at the top when the chlorine broke,
right?
You put electrons into Sigma Star.
So you can do it with light as well as with some homo attacking.
Okay?
So we have,
um,
uh,
in fact,
I said Lumo when I was talking about athlete,
I've meant homo up above I think some three or four minutes ago.
Okay?
So the bond breaks,
but it doesn't break into ions.
It breaks one electron going each way because that's easier.
Okay,
so now and notice that we draw curved arrows for that too.
But you draw arrows with a single bar rather than a double bar when it's just
one electron rather than a pair of electrons.
It's executed the motion we're talking about.
Okay,
so now we have to chlorine atoms and now we can do the trick with the chlorine
atom because we have this so mo and it can mix with the ch bond to make a new
bond.
That is one electron in the ch bond now goes each way.
One goes to complete the pair to make Hcl,
and the other one is left on carbon.
Right?
So it's very much like the reaction above,
but it's single electrons that are doing the moving instead of electron pairs.
And the Nice thing about this is you still have a radical,
and it must be.
So if you start with something with an odd number of electrons and react it with
something with an even number of electrons,
you must be left at the end with an odd number of electrons,
right?
Ch three is such a radical and it can react with something to break another bond
and it reacts with the Weakest Bond.
Chlorine,
right?
So now you have methyl chloride,
you've incorporated chlorine into the al Qaeda,
and you have a chlorine atom.
Why is it neat that you have a chlorine atom?
What's great about that?
Dana?
What did you say?
That's what you needed at the beginning.
That's why you used light in order to get that,
but you don't need any more light now,
right?
That can go back and start over again.
So it's a chain reaction.
It's called a free radical chain reaction.
And so you can get lots of products from just one initial photon of light that
started this chain along.
So these are two completely different ways.
The first,
the top is an addition of chlorine to an alkene and the bottom is called free
radical substitution of chlorine for hydrogen and involves,
so Moe's rather than homos and Lumos Chris
second
from the first.
Yep.
Does it break a second molecule rather than using the other?
Because they have to find one another,
right?
They've gone off.
It'll take forever before they by chance encounter one another and solution.
They'll react with many molecules.
If you try to generate too many chlorine radical so the concentration gets high,
then their concentration will drop again or not get so high because they find
one another and combined.
But as long as they're rare,
they can survive.
You know what the license plate of New Hampshire says on it?
Live?
Free or die.
Okay.
I use that joke later on.
Okay,
1830 to 1850s we have this substitution or type or unitary theory.
It doesn't involve the plus minus stuff.
Max.
Is it kind of like what?
I couldn't hear clearly.
Yeah,
they involved.
That's a free radical chain reaction.
The ozone reduction.
Yeah.
We'll talk about that a little bit later,
I hope.
Okay.
So there's more trouble for radicals for do you mind 1839 and that is that they
had this reverence asset.
Teal radical had been discovered by liebig.
So there was this great element that would,
that would go survive from reaction to reaction.
But here was a reaction with chlorine of this kind that Dubai had been studying,
where you start with a Siddique acid acid,
teal Oah,
react it with chlorine,
and you get a chloro asset deal.
So the element has been changed.
It's been transmuted.
It doesn't go unchanged from reaction reaction.
Right?
And in fact,
that goes even further.
It can react again to give die chloro asset teal or try chloro asset deal.
All the hydrogens can be substituted as we now know by the kind of mechanism,
the Somo mechanism,
we just studied free radical,
uh,
chlorination chain reaction.
So hydrogen can be substituted by an equivalent amount of height,
halogen or oxygen,
right?
But all of these things you get when you change a radical into something else,
when you transmute it,
have similar properties.
All of these acids at CDEC acid chloro is CDEC,
dichloride,
Hassidic,
trickler OCT are all acids.
They all taste sharp and so on,
right?
So they're similar.
So what?
Uh,
so they don't change the type.
That's where this idea of type theory cave on.
You get the same type of molecule even after you have a substitution.
So by 1853 four types were recognized as prevalent.
One was water,
another was hydrogen,
and other was hydrochloric acid.
And another was ammonia.
So for example,
you could have these structures in this drawing with a curly bracket,
like this was the notation used by the people who did type theory.
So you have water,
hydrochloric acid,
hydrogen and ammonia,
and you could exchange,
make exchanges for the hydrogen right substitution.
So that,
for example,
with ammonia,
you could substitute Ethel for hydrogen and you could get ethylamine or die
ethylamine or triethylamine.
But these were all basic,
why would we say their basic of the sense of acid base?
Why do we say they're,
they're,
they're basically react with acids by true,
yeah.
They all have the unshared para nitrogen we would say,
but they said they're just the same type of molecule.
Okay.
Or you could have ethyl alcohol,
which is of the water type or,
uh,
or the potassium salt thereof,
which they would say is,
is the potassium Ethel analog of water or of the HCL.
You could have Ethel iodide where you exchanged hydrogen with Ethel and exchange
chloride with,
with iodide.
Okay.
But in fact,
these two things could react with one another to give this ether,
which is another thing that's still like water clear liquid and so on.
Okay.
Fairly unreactive.
Uh,
so this particular reaction was,
was uh,
named for the work in 1850 of Williamson in England.
So it's called the Williamson ether synthesis.
And we'll talk about that again later.
But it's quite an old reaction.
So how about the theory of these,
these types?
So notice it's unitary,
not dualistic.
They're just things that,
that are holistic,
right?
Not plus minus do said that molecules are like planetary systems,
like the sun in its planets held together by a force resembling gravitation,
but acting in accord with much more complicated laws.
He didn't think it was gravity,
but it was some forest holds this,
uh,
this assemblage together and Williamson,
that Alexander William Williamson,
who we just mentioned making ethers said,
f,
this is something new.
And notice it's because it's a very young guy that has a new idea,
not like these,
uh,
imagination starved older people.
I mean,
at this age,
at this time,
Dumas was 40 years old.
He's four sevenths as old as I am,
right?
So he was really getting over the hill.
A formula made,
the young guy says,
may be used as an actual image
of what we rationally supposed to be,
the arrangement of constituent atoms.
This is entirely new formulas.
At least since Dalton,
we're only what the elements were and what ratio is there and not how they're
arranged.
Right?
But he said,
we can,
we can think that they're,
uh,
that they're like an orrery as which is an image of what we conclude to be the
arrangement of our planetary system.
Do you know what an Ori is?
It's,
it's a thing like this,
you know,
where you have a mechanical model of the solar system and you'd turn a crank and
the moon goes around the earth,
the earth goes around the sun,
and a bunch of moons go around Saturn and so on.
Have you seen these devices?
And that was very popular in those,
there was a show of Joseph,
right,
of Darby here at Yale last summer.
Uh,
so beautiful bromide,
you remember,
is a residue of radical dualism,
right?
Plus butyl minus bromide,
but there's another name for butyl bromide.
Do you know what it is?
You know the other name for butyl bromide?
You've meant we didn't,
we haven't talked about systematic nomenclature yet,
so you probably don't,
but it's also called Bromo butane.
But Bravo.
Butane is not two words.
It's one word.
Right?
And that's a relic of the unitary theory,
the substitution theory that it's butane in which a hydrogen has been replaced
by bromine.
Okay.
So Brett's alias in 1838 when these,
uh,
things came along said by reacting chlorine with ordinary ether,
Dumont produce the very interesting compound,
which he reckoned according to the theory of substitutions to be an ether,
in which four atoms of chlorine replace four atoms of hydrogen.
Right?
So,
so do says that in these types you can replace hydrogen by chlorine.
What would parts alias think about that?
What kind of theory is he?
Is He,
uh,
advocating?
Remember we talked last time about pets alias.
He was the originator of dualism plus minus.
What would he of replacing hydrogen by chlorine?
Lucas?
Right?
So here's what he said,
and element as eminently electronegative as chlorine would never be able to
enter into an organic radical.
This idea is contrary to the first principles of chemistry.
Okay.
And in that same paper in 1838,
he talked about tartrate losing an atom of water,
which you mean it's a molecule at 190.
But the interesting thing about that is not that transformation,
but that this is the first time the letter r was used to talk about a generic
radical r stands for radical,
right?
So we still use that.
So,
so much of what we do nowadays derives from this period.
Okay.
So the,
the principal journal at that time in,
in chemistry was the analogy dare came on pharmacy,
which was originally a Nolen to pharmacy.
Uh,
but Comey was added and you see who put it out,
it says with the collaboration of Dumas in Paris and Graham in London,
and Graham is one of the guys out at the front of the building here,
edited by volar and leaving.
But actually it was leaving.
He was the one and later the journal came to be called Lee beaks.
I'm Nolen right?
So he was the one in charge,
but he'd added these other people just sort of for show.
Okay.
So in 1840 [inaudible] there were a series of papers published.
The first of them was by so-called collaborator,
do Ma on the law of substitution and the theory of types.
This was a 40 page paper and it begins with this question number one,
there can one substitute the elements that play their role in any simple or
compound substance equivalent for equivalent.
So could you make a new Adam takes the role of an old atom and you won't be
surprised that in 40 pages he concludes the answer is yes,
but immediately following this is a note from the editor which says remarks on
the previous paper and it's by j l at the bottom,
Eustace liebig and he says begins,
I am a far cry from sharing the ideas that monsieur do.
Maya has linked to the so called laws of the substitution theory.
And then there's another paper by another Frenchman Palouse on the substitution
law of Monsieur Dumas.
And after that lengthy paper,
there's a letter a on the law of substitution and the theory of types,
uh,
with a footnote that says it was a letter to use this leak.
And you notice it's dated Paris and it's the only paper that's in French in this
particular issue.
And it's,
there's another page.
It's got some curious formulas in them that have a lot of chlorine.
We'll come back to that in just a second.
And it's by a chemist that no one had heard of before called s c h vintner this
letter to leaving.
And then the next paper is also on the reaction of chlorine with the chlorides
of ethanol and methanol and several points of the ether theory by [inaudible]
who was a French chemist.
Now this is that letter translated Paris 1st of March,
1840 miss year.
I am eager to communicate to you one of the most striking facts of organic
chemistry.
I have confirmed the substitution theory in an extremely remarkable and
completely unexpected manner.
Only now can one appreciate the great value of this theory and foresee the
immense discoveries that it promises to reveal.
So it starts,
it's got a complicated a description of all the light was used sometimes and the
various distillations and crystallizations and the crystals are described.
But he started with Manganese Acetate,
which had this formula with the asset deal radical in it and was able to
chlorinate to substitute the hydrogens with chlorine.
So there's already a validation to the substitution theory,
but it went further.
A subsequent reaction,
uh,
exchange the O and manganese oxide with chlorine and a further reaction replaced
the manganese itself with chlorine.
Uh,
and then the final reaction,
the PSD,
Raci stands for place,
the carbon with chlorine and the oxygen with chlorine,
but still it preserved it's type right?
So it was the same kind of substance still,
even though it was entirely chlorine for all I know in the d color eyes,
and that is bleaching action of chlorine and hydrogen is replaced by chlorine in
the cloth,
which is now being bleached in England,
preserves its type according to the substitution laws,
I believe,
however,
that Adam for Adam,
substitution of carbon by chlorine is my own discovery.
I hope you will take note of this in your journal and be assured of my sincerest
regards,
et Sch employer.
And there's a footnote,
which is I have learned that there is already in the London shops a cloth of
chlorine thread,
which is very much sought after and preferred above all others for nightcaps
underwear,
et cetera.
Now,
this is,
you'll be surprised the pun because that the name is pronounced Schindler or
swindler.
So where do you think this came from?
Leaving didn't have enough sense of humor to do such a thing.
Who was the joker?
Volar so Voler had sent this in a letter to parts alias and alias thought it was
so fun that he forwarded the liebig and to voters consternation Liebing
published it,
right,
which didn't make Duma the happier.
Right?
So this was,
uh,
leaving at least thought it was funny,
I guess.
Okay.
So at 1849,
uh,
Colby prepared the free methyl radical,
the actual element,
which had never been prepared before.
Ch three,
he did it by electrolysis.
So when you electrolyze a CD Cassatt it turns out you can get hydrogen,
hydrogen gas and CO2 and what analyzed for ch three.
Right?
So he had prepared the actual radical.
Now,
of course it was discovered,
uh,
10 years later that he hadn't prepared ch three,
it had that analysis.
But actually it was c two h six.
It was the dimer of ch three.
Okay.
But at the time it was thought to be justification of the radical theory.
So these two theories were competing with one another,
and ironically,
both the theories were supported by reactions that actually did involve
radicals.
So the oxidation of Benzaldehyde,
the first reaction that generated benzoyl did in fact involve benzoyl.
It was a somo reaction in which a hydrogen atom was abstracted and the
chlorination,
as we've already seen of a,
of a hydrocarbon,
like methane involves pulling a hydrogen atom off,
and that electrolysis did indeed generate the methyl radicals,
but they were so reactive,
they found one another and dimerize to c two h six so it's just sort of curious
that all these reactions did indeed involve free radicals,
but no one was truly aware of it.
So next time we'll see what resolved all this.